yeah I welcome to this video playing
black in five minutes against rst it's a
GM for maybe the abbreviation of some
sorts there's no name in there don't
know it's this is some Ukrainian yeah it
can be anyone do Ukraine has gotten so
many GMS okay we got an italian game
with d3 the one of those relatively
quiet lines that don't do any M threaten
too much yeah here black has a funny
possibility and I'll do that I haven't
canceled yet and you can really do that
g5 it some 44 blitz chess it sets
perfectly viable and even in other forms
of Jess it's not it's not clear at all
so let's let's go for this
nigeria probably p.m. need to all rights
it's already tricky I cannot take for
instance this instantly losers Bishop
takes Queen moves and Bishop e3 and over
so he needs to play something else maybe
this really but take h2 and Queen edge
for this looks like a massive attack
isn't it okay let's let's do this let's
move this here anyway and be quick about
it so this yeah why not isn't this okay
maybe he's got Queen f3 because f seven
eggs this could be if I take first and
then Bishop g4 hmm or wait wait wait
wait maybe is
why should I even go coming h3 of Queen
age 3 is also not not entirely stupid
Bishop e3 King taken to Queen f3 let's
think about this for a moment yeah this
also
if I just don't night the eight then
what is he doing after that maybe g3
mm-hmm I can take if I take first here
and then now then he takes with the pawn
but it's isn't this sir isn't this so
good I can take with a tape with the
bishop even of Jaws nonsense hmm yes but
maybe this it's it's it's it's not bad
what is what what was my idea ok let's
do this it looks so it looks strong
I should have calculated least a bit of
deform and why didn't I do that you form
I can probably really just take g3 I
think I can take III Bishop takes ok I
thought I could play Bishop g4 now I
hope this is possible otherwise this was
really just bonkers takes on h3 Bishop
e2 check and if he takes on g4 Luke g4
and he doesn't have f3 because of this
monster on a seven and of course I just
threaten Bishop f3 at the Queen so if it
takes Bishop e2 would check 92 Bishop f
three wins and King moves i take III and
then have one so it should really am win
the house basically I can take with the
bishop it's just an exchange okay but in
exchange is not bad I can also just take
f1 and f2 okay then this is probably am
enough
it takes should f3 is nonsense probably
oh cool I didn't see this movie at all
hmm oh that's probably not a good thing
yeah Jesus just back probably yeah I
didn't think about f3 at all and then
this is probably yeah by far not the
best it's still a properly very good for
black they may need still a big attacker
but I'm not winning instantly which I
really thought I would hmm ok no but
it's not fun for him to play as well
what what what is he supposed to do now
I can just cancel and them and pile up
on the G farm and when it's not clear
what what what is next move is exactly
age five yeah okay so maybe not the the
maximum yeah but it's not bad
02 yeah Wow yep and it's equal don't
believe it I really let him out of this
nonsense Jesus hi this will be painful
one of those cases where you know that
the engine afterwards tells you that you
could one unlike five occasions I'm
pretty sure about that
time warning at least that's a fairly
solid position Bishop c3m got needs
tactic I think he really overlooked that
good defense is it winning or not I mean
okay at times the win as well yeah it is
winning in fact yeah why why shouldn't I
mean two points connected by by by the
time not and this was lucky to windows
end game initially I think I was worse
in the end game a bit but this this
trick was very neat rc3 but they're
really i need to know at this position
how I could have won the game minus six
let's let's show it it just takes on III
I was thought about this free flame
but I thought that I can still take on
youtube oh yeah I can just take okay
this is easy and brilliant I mean this
this is some this is what I didn't so I
can I also could take yeah is this good
this is just a draw it still looks
terrible but I can I can do this now
it's sort of like a transposition to my
queen h3 idea now this maid is coming T
I can take yeah yeah now anthem okay
once the house I didn't I didn't really
see Queen h3 here this was the problem I
saw this and then queena three are there
still will be G 2 so this is so this is
winning as well worth did I calculate
that yeah there must there did Adam the
dome should be young should be winning
but I didn't see it really yeah thanks
for watching interesting game
nonetheless